welcome back to the five the president
of the united states has tested positive
for the coronavirus and we have some
breaking news with our john roberts john
what do you have jesse good afternoon to
you we've known that this was going to
happen for some time but it's just now
we're just now able to report it the
president is expected to depart the
white house soon to go up to
walter reed national military medical
center uh for
evaluation and a series of tests just to
have a baseline if you will of where he
is with the coronavirus obviously
as you mentioned jesse earlier at the
age of 74 and a little bit overweight
the president
is in a risk category for the
development of severe
severe coronavirus disease so doctors up
there and walter reed just want to get a
sense of where the president is
again as we reported at the top of the
hour dr
sean connolly who is the president's
personal physician here at the white
house
gave the president a dose of a still
experimental not yet fda approved drug
it's called a polyclonal antibody made
by a company
called regeneron which in phase one two
and three
uh human trials has shown a very good
effectiveness
at reducing the viral load of people who
are not in the hospital
the president obviously has been at the
white house here all day hopefully he
will be able to return
to the white house later on tonight uh i
imagine that uh
doctors there will also get some sort of
an idea of what his viral load is
clearly there are much more
sophisticated
uh machines up there at walter reed than
there are here at the white house
though the quality of carry gets it here
at the white house is top notch so
we expect that a helicopter will be
landing soon
to take the president up there there are
already cameras in place for the
president's arrival
we have not again been able to report
this until now but the president
expected very soon to be headed up to
walter reed
national military medical center and of
course our thoughts and prayers are with
him
and the first lady as they battle
through this virus
nobody wants to get coronavirus a lot of
people get it very mildly but as the
president has stated
in interviews and at some of his
campaign rallies
he knows some people who one day were
barely sick with it
the next day they're in the hospital the
day after that they're on a ventilator
and then
seemingly a day after that they have
expired so the president
wants to make sure that uh he gets the
very very best of care
that his physicians uh want him to get
which is why he'll be traveling up to
walter reed in just a little while jesse
john thanks for the update let's bring
in brett bear host a special report
so brad this is pretty serious now going
to walter reed obviously
it's precautionary but they're
[Music]
taking it very seriously as they should
yeah we're told that he's going to
remain there for a few days actually
jesse uh so it's not just
fly up there and get a test and come
home uh
this is going to world renowned medical
facility
right up the road in bethesda but he is
being transported there
at an abundance of caution he we're told
is
having mild symptoms a light fever
some mild symptoms of coronavirus
is a bit fatigued according to his
physician
but he is going to be making that marine
one trip
to walter reed national military medical
center and there are
amazing facilities there and doctors who
are on top of this
but it's serious what does it tell you
brett that they're
going to have him there for a few days
well it tells you that it's just not a
routine in and out
you're not just getting tested i mean
they want to make sure that he is
getting everything he needs and perhaps
it's more of this
treatment he's already received as
mentioned by the white house doctor the
regeneron that
john just mentioned perhaps it's
something else but they'll be able to
monitor him
a lot better a lot more sophisticated
as far as the equipment there at walter
reed national military medical center
all right brett stay with us